MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.20--
Special Relativity.
In this short video, we look
at the historic backdrop,
the time in which Einstein
was able to develop the theory
of special relativity.
What were people thinking?
What was the physics
landscape of the time?
How was technology developed?
And how did all those things
come together for Einstein
to thrive and come forward with
those important discoveries
in physics?
We have to go back to 1900,
around that time in which
Einstein was able to break
through, break out, and come up
with completely new
ideas in physics.
Before we go into the
discussion of the timelines,
I'd like you to be invited to
come to Geneva, to Switzerland,
to Bern, to Zurich-- to
the places in which this
all happened.
Especially Bern is
a historic town,
wasn't destroyed in
the Second World War.
And if you walk
down the streets,
here is a picture
of me two years ago
in front of the Einstein house.
The streets are basically
unchanged for the last 150
years, so you look
up into the window,
and you see Einstein
looking down at you.
So if you go back
200 years, in Italy,
people like Volta
and others started
to make use of
electromagnetic effects.
The first batteries
were developed.
And a theory, a wave theory
of light was developed.
That then let-- slowly
developed into the theory
of electromagnetism
and the understanding
of those phenomena.
And the very same
time, in Europe,
the first railroad
systems were developed.
Electromagnetic
induction was understood.
And then in the
1860s, Maxwell was
able to put all
of those concepts
together in his famous Maxwell
equations, which are discussed
at length in 8.02.
People were then,
because of the railroads
but also because of
telegraphic cables,
able to communicate and
move over a larger distance
in a shorter amount of time.
And that led to the need
of synchronizing clocks.
To that point, in each town
had one or a few clock towers.
And you just read off the time,
and it was the time of day.
There was no need
to be able to tell
what time is it in
London when you have
your breakfast in Munich or
what time the store opens
in a different city.
There was no need for this
kind of synchronization.
But with the expansion
of railroads,
specifically, there was
a need to understand
when a train when a train
is on a track and such
that it doesn't intersect
with another train, avoiding
collisions.
You also want to know when you
have to be at a train station
in order to catch the train.
Those things became
important, and they
led to patents filed around
this time and also later on.
On the theory of light,
people developed all kinds
of ideas and conflicting
ideas of, for example,
mechanical models
of light, which
relied on the existence of a
medium in which light travels.
And we'll discuss
this at length.
In the 1880s, there's
a new phenomena
in the structure of physics.
Up to this point,
there was a professor
of physics at an institute.
He had a chair, and everybody
was working for them.
But then there was
a change in the way
physics research was conducted,
such that there started
to be a division of labor
between experimental physicists
and theoretical physicists.
Around this time, Thomas
Edison developed light bulbs,
meaning that light
and electricity,
those two things became
more woven together.
Electromagnetic waves
were discovered.
And Michelson and Morley
conducted the experiment.
And they did not find a medium
which carried light waves.
And we'll discuss the
Michelson-Morley experiment
in much more depth.
But this was basically
the backdrop.
Michelson and Morley-- the
idea of electromagnetic waves,
how do they actually travel.
What is the speed in
which they travel?
What are the medium?
And how does this all interact?
So Einstein was born into this.
He was born in Ulm, a German
town, a small German town,
on March 14, 1879, on Pi Day.
He spent his youth in
Munich, where his father--
he had an electrical
company, a company
which provided electrical
services-- for example,
for the Oktoberfest in Munich.
And his business
went up and down
and had to be relocated
later into Italy.
It was a difficult
and interesting time.
So Einstein went to
school in Munich,
in a gymnasium in Munich.
And at some point,
it was time for him
to go to military service.
And he avoided this
by becoming stateless.
He then wanted to enroll in
a university in Switzerland,
Polytechnic of the
Eidgenossische Technische
Hochschule in Zurich.
But he wasn't quite admitted,
mainly because his French
wasn't quite sufficient.
So he had to go an extra round
of studying in order to be then
admitted to the Polytechnic.
One of his mentors at the
time was Herr Professor Weber.
He was a leading
physicist there.
And they had an
interesting relationship,
which I come back to
in a little while.
While studying in
Zurich, Einstein
met his wife, Mileva Maric.
She was also a physics student,
one of the few female physics
students there.
And they fell in love,
and they married.
And they had a child together,
or children together.
In 1900, Einstein graduated.
He wasn't the best
student in class.
Neither was Mileva Maric.
And he had a hard
time finding a career.
So he wanted to stay
at the university
and enter an academic career,
and that required the mentors
to be in favor of this.
And since Einstein didn't quite
develop a good relationship
with Herr Weber and the
other professors around,
they didn't want him there.
They didn't promote his career.
So he didn't know
quite what to do--
went back to his
parents, to Italy,
and didn't get any
traction from where he was.
And he was quite anxious
about this, which
is visible in letters he wrote.
But he had good friends there.
He had a good friend, Marcel
Grossmann, specifically,
who helped him get into,
after some back and forth,
a position as a lower
level patent clerk
in a patent office in Bern.
And so this was the
starting point for a career.
So he had this-- he
was a patent clerk.
He had a lot of time on
his hands beyond that.
And that started something
which was called the Olympia
Academy, which consisted
of a group of people who
studied with and
friends of Einstein,
including Marcel Grossmann.
And they talked and spent
time, took long walks,
spend time drinking,
partying, if you want,
but specifically
talking about physics.
And in this framework, Einstein
was able to develop this ideas.
And then 1905 came--
not in a sudden, but in 1905, he
was able, out of this context,
to develop five very,
very important papers.
The first one was
on light quantum.
He was able to
describe the emission
and absorption of light.
In April, then, which was
part of his PhD thesis,
he was able to characterize
the size of molecules.
And in May, he was able to
show the existence of atoms.
He was basically
demonstrating this
by following Brownian
random motion of atoms.
And then in June, he wrote a
paper named electrodynamics
of moving bodies.
And that is the paper in which
he discovers or describes
special relativity.
On further review, he
discovered that there's
a consequence of
special relativity
that energy and mass are
equivalent in his famous
equation E equals mc squared.
And we'll come to this, as well.
So this is basically the
framework of this lecture.
If you then move forward into
general relativity, which
was developed by
Einstein in 1915,
you can then, again,
follow the development
of signs of quantum mechanics
of general relativity
and the conundrum of
describing those two
concepts at the very same
time, in which, then, Einstein
lived and moved.
His career developed
then from there on,
not instantly but
systematically.
He had a call as a
professor in Berlin later on
and, after the Nazis
took over in Germany,
decided to flee Germany.
And he moved to
the United States,
where he took on a
position in Princeton.
The rest is history,
as you want,
and we'll hear more
about this tomorrow.